[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a long story how I got here I won't
tell it now
but it has something to do with this
song
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
I've waited here for you Everlong
[Music]
to
I throw myself into and out of the read
out of and she say doo-doo-doo-doo
[Music]
calm down then waste away with me
jam
slow how you wanted it to be I'm over my
head
[Music]
and I want
[Music]
when I sing along with you
if everything could ever feel this real
forever
if anything could ever be this good
yeah
the only thing I'll ever ask of you you
gotta promise not stop when I say
she said
[Applause]
[Music]
breathe out so I can greet you in
and hold you in
and
oh I know you've always been out of
I
[Music]
yes I wanted
[Music]
when I sing along with you
[Music]
if everything could ever feel this real
forever
[Music]
anything could ever be this good
again
the only thing I'll ever ask of you you
gotta promise not to stop when I say
where
she said
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're not sing-along with you
[Music]
if everything could ever feel this real
forever
[Music]
anything could ever be this good
yeah
the only thing I'll ever ask of you you
gotta promise not to stop when I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Pedro
hey bro